Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look
at the outline for these series of courses.
And from there, we're going to start talking
about layered materials.
So let's get started.
First up, we'll look at layered materials overall.
We'll look at their use,
layered materials the old way,
layered materials Megascans,
and layered materials the new way.
From there, we'll take a look
at material parameter collections.
From there, we'll look at what is an MPC,
setting it up,
and we'll go break that down appropriately.
Next, we'll look at subsurface materials
and parallax control.
We'll look at creating a subsurface material,
focusing on a particular look such as Jade.
And then we'll take a look at creating ice as an overview
and some complex features and looks you can get.
From there, we'll look at Unreal subsurface profile,
and we'll look at an overview for that.
From there, we'll also talk about some pro tips
when it comes to working with subsurface materials.
We'll then look at using a parallax occlusion mapping
when it comes to material function.
And then we'll also take a sneak peek at substrate,
which is a class we actually have currently
and something that you can request.
So let's go ahead and jump in.
So let's go ahead and take a look at layered materials.
So the use of layered materials.
You'll see layered materials with 3D Studio Max,
Maya and Houdini,
and Unreal gives you the power to be able to do that
within the engine itself.
Now, the reason why we would do this,
it really does prevent a noodle fest
and allows us to combine elements
such as snow on rock, moss on wood,
or even grime on a tiled surface.
But there are three ways that we can approach this.
So one, we can use the old way,
which uses multiple material functions,
and you're able to stack them in such a way
so that you can actually get them
to be able to do what you want.
Next, we can also do it via mega scans,
but we also have a new way
using layered materials and blend materials.
And that actually keeps things a lot cleaner.
Doesn't make it lighter on memory,
but it definitely does make it cleaner.
So again, using it, it really is helpful.
The old way and the new way
does really prevent a noodle fest.
Now, this is a bit of the old way here
where you'll see material functions active,
and you'll see things overall are very much cleaner
than over here if we just built these out
and stack them in such a way
to get them to be able to imitate that same functionality.
So it's really there, the old way and the new way,
to keep things cleaner overall.
Now, again, I emphasize that the new way
keeps things even more cleaner and trimmer,
and so that you can actually get to things a bit easier
and things make maybe a little bit more sense.
But again, it doesn't necessarily make it lighter.
That light function or getting it to be lighter
is all dependent on several things,
such as the resolution of your texture
and also on the complexity of that shader.
So the old way, again, allows us to be able to go in here
and build our material out.
In these materials, the parent material,
we can actually build some material functions.
And I should say that you can bring into that material.
And you should be familiar at this time
with material functions and how they work.
So these material functions will allow us
to stack a material together and get a new result.
And you'll see here, six will be our final destination.
That's the nice thing about that.
You can nest it within a parent material.
And in that parent material,
we can actually have these material functions
to be able to get the look that we want
for our final output.
So let's go ahead and start making that material.
And we'll do that in the next video.